I know who Nina is she knows who I am
we've been so transparent about each
other's past she's a angel she's
had long-term boyfriends her whole life
every guy in the world wants to date her
only a few could say they got to I'm the
one that was lucky enough to lock her
down uh it's so stupid that I have to
come on here and like clarify the fact
that my supermodel girlfriend he's had
an amazing career and has built an
amazing life for herself got Paparazzi
with her exes like yeah she took
pictures with their exes yes guys came
up to her I wanted to take photos you
can kind of tell when a guy has a more
like blue pilled mentality a bit more
naive and that's why a lot of times guys
will say in the manosphere that you can
have money but it doesn't mean you
understand women and you can get women
but it doesn't mean that you understand
them